all right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 57
and it's a glorious Easter Sunday and we
are back at the roundtable on the Lord's
Day I'm very excited about our very
special guests we've got Tori VCS no
mascot Xbox see if thieves digital game
rentals maybe some ray tracing to
discuss so we can get right into it I
want to introduce a Lord was not only a
pioneer in the realm of gaming but whose
journey in this industry is one that
truly demands tremendous respect this
Lord is a true gamer in every sense of
the word and his passion is always
exemplified and everything he does
from his informative podcasts at your
recommendations with his amazing team
all done with high quality production
value introducing the founder and host
of the original next level gaming
podcast the Lord of gaming journalism
III attendances and our very own sake of
brethren at heart making his
long-awaited debut into the realm of the
Lords my man Lord Stinger MLG how are
you doing sir oh my god how do I follow
that whoa let's go oh my goodness for a
minute man he's talking about someone
else me oh my god guys this has been it
has been a long journey to get to the
realm and it is an absolute honor and
pleasure my my friend absolutely very
huge huge fan of you watching and as you
guys do and we had to get the treaty two
kingdoms man is it has a ride you know I
bring I bring many greetings and and
Easter salutations from my from my
humble crew and guys this is let me tell
you I'm enormous fans of the iron Lords
as well you guys are fantastic I love
you
show I love what you guys do and I was
very happy to become very quick friends
with with all of you and I am just I'm
absolutely delighted to be here in the
room much much appreciated now of course
you were lured at what you do so it's
only right there and show you that
proper respect at the round table
that is absolutely mutual respect my
friends no doubt absolutely we got some
fun today we are gonna have a great time
do it Wow oh yeah so let's introduce
those Four Horsemen of gaming I don't
know how long we'll have all four my
co-host with the co-host my brother from
another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the how of the young BOTS
mommy
Lord addict how are you doing sir not
much it's nice to be here I'll probably
have to leave in the next five minutes I
stay as long as I could appreciate you
man I didn't think we'd get you I know
you got a lot of responsibilities going
on yeah I mean so we figure you know we
take what we can get we're glad that and
of course we have our most technical
gaming Lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also the sastra Thomas this Tarou flat
profile Illuminati himself mummy head
Lord sovereign how you doing sir as well
but since I couldn't get any gaming on
yesterday because wifey was off from
work which I didn't know so that my
gaming was folded yesterday completely
but I am that earned me a reprieve today
so she went to Mass and whatnot this
morning and she let me beat for you use
old Moses mi-8 the ladies bless her
heart
dude L head of course got the Incredible
Hulk Ernest aka the XS game the Lord of
combat experience Lord as you know it
was he opened that up was like yeah this
is typical of this generation they don't
know when a talk when not go get your
chocolates sweetness
don't get your sweetness they got a
downstairs we'll have it coming what sir
let me tell you last night
oh boy I anticipated last night I don't
know why I fell for the crap I fell for
the crap mr. sensitivity aka Anthony
Joshua the sweetness of boxing oh it was
a production last night it was such a
production for the coronation of the
sweet champ make a sweetness Joshua
um before Joseph Parker shout-out to the
nice guy Joseph Parker it was a love
fest last night after every realm they
shook hands all the way to listen I like
a little maintenance in my fighters I
like my fighters to have a little I'm
trying to kill you in here tonight my
fight is to feel like they want to make
sure that you never walk again fighter
shout out to the real champ
Deontay Wilder the real champ the champ
that has a mean streak in and he's
shaking hands with you when a contract
is fine he's designed to dis do remove
your spine out your body I sub-zero
alright so I understand why Anthony
Joshua and Eddie heard there's such
afraid of this man this is terrible man
I will go in there and rip your head off
your shoulder he's trying to make sure
that you equivalent mess on the mat
beautiful yeah highlight film he's
trying to make the ESPN highlight reel
when he steps in away with you this is
an only goal like he stated born Oh what
was it the Breakfast Club
yeah trying to catch a body in a ring -
Dion say wow this is exactly what he
said now last night we have sweetness in
the ring sweetness the production was so
terrible these sort of ruffles are paid
off
you saw the judges was paid off the corn
ate sweetness understand this is exactly
what's going on today we have a little
situation
[Applause]
listen and truly this because last night
this is exactly what this generation is
sweet older men these are older men this
situation has gotten out of here fellas
and I thought I addressed this before
well obviously me addressing the
situation does
give you insight to my character my
character does not go walpole with what
troubles you it's on your movie clicking
up the clicking up don't hang with him
don't talk to him because he says some
things about him and huh stop that I
don't come from that that is not in my
DNA second hand beef and I will not be
part of this clicking up thing mmm you
stop in the bag you stop in the cash
because when everybody is all inclusive
everybody eats but when you separate and
segregate and you start to talk about
people behind back back how does that
make you look you are no better than the
man that you claim the ostracize that's
a good point that's a good plan
we used to handle our business in the
street and I'm not talking about
fighting because none of y'all out here
fighting sweetness last night all right
so we walked in the arcade I had a
problem with you I will not ever
disrespect our female podcasters by
referring to these men as women because
these women have absolutely no problems
online I actually see a lot of men
having problems with them and I want to
stay you guys are gonna have to get it
together
Thanks you guys are gonna have to get it
together if you have a problem with a
man to trust that man play that man
online please
again turning into a sport let people
see that we can rise above the pettiness
yeah let me jump in right quickly cuz
I'm gonna double down on it I mean at
the end of the day like I said we all
have this one single threat that brings
us together and that is gaming that is
what we all enjoy doing right so at the
end of the day this is a hobby we had to
have some fun and to your comic King I
definitely seen the the banter on
Twitter I've seen the communications and
this is the thing at the end of the day
the Iowa podcast we respect everybody
you know if you do your thing and you're
a lord in gaming you're gonna be on the
roundtable and we're gonna have some
guests that not everybody's gonna like
but at the end of the day what brings us
together is the common thread of gaming
we can't lose sight of that I think
that's what's happening right now people
lose sight of that and it's all this
clicking and high school mentality and
don't talk to this one and don't talk to
that one I'm gonna tell you right now
I'm gonna have someone to show you
because we all gamers that's what we're
here to do have some fun if you know if
that's not your cup of tea that guess
hey maybe we just don't see you that
episode and hopefully you come back
hopefully I don't even have to get to
that but uh thank you Noah King but I
want to triple down on this trip
gnostics we are not conformed to Xbox or
any system you have a better version of
a game I'm buying it okay so I think we
appreciate all the support all the love
that we got from everybody sacks on
Twitter on YouTube everybody who's been
on our show everybody who's liked our
show everybody who spoken well of us we
completely appreciate that at the same
time we needed everyone to understand
that at no point in time we're all
grown-ass men old grown-ass men are not
grizzled at this point in our lives
to come to peer pressure high finance is
what it is absolutely ridiculous if you
listen to anything that we've said over
the past year or so or more that we've
been this this group as a podcast and
you've heard our stories about how we
grew up in where we grew up
mm-hm guys we're here because we didn't
succumb to peer pressure like if you
talk about king mice you feel about king
myself and Cognito pretty grew up in the
South Bronx the 90s exactly all this
Twitter beef and don't is not serious to
us I'm trying to catch that accent my
mother my mother's from the Bronx oh let
me tell you I mean this stuff is
irrelevant says we're here because we
didn't succumb to the very easy to
succumb to peer pressure of the 90s in
New York City and the Bronx like this
was grimy this wasn't the definition of
a hood the archetype of hood was this
exactly he did something different we
went left with it and that's why we're
here so that's no point in time is this
stuff gonna bother us let me let me also
if I might go for it go for it listen no
treaty time you know even though I'm not
technically the oldest person here I am
still I am still right up there and what
people have to remember is we were here
gaming long before Twitter mm-hmm we
were here gaming long before Facebook
mmm long before forums long before these
places where people could get on and and
act tough to each other from five six
seven states away keyboard gangsters
exactly we will survive Twitter so you
know
I left Twitter I stopped last week I
check it down again because that's how I
how I got you know that's how I've been
communicating with some people I know
kind of a DM but as far as the overall
gaming Twitter I don't need it see I you
know I I can't I'm I'm of the mind that
I have too much going on and not enough
time to go through the drama and the
nonsense mm-hmm so I chose to I'm
choosing to build up a different way you
guys you know you guys are all part of
or at least if you're not invited
kognito is gotta give you the the invite
to the dist you know we have our own
discord mm-hm and it's invite-only
and i've it's just if you haven't gotten
an invite to it it's for a reason I even
haven't gotten to you yet or you just
not what I want
and I I'm of the mind that if I'm gonna
spend this much time talking to people
and having a good time or talk games I
want to talk about I want to talk about
what's good going on yeah of course
there's there's you know complaints to
the levee against things we don't like
stuff like that absolutely but your
opinion should be respected and allowed
and then when that stops I got anything
for you and if the discussion that needs
to be had then the discussion needs to
be had and I'm going behind people's
backs not really not not trying to get
people to rally against XYZ person it's
absolutely ridiculous oh one other thing
I need to add to this I mean I know it's
Easter Sunday I'm looking at our chat
and I'm grateful for everyone who's here
absolutely much appreciated on yesterday
it's not as popping as it normally is
and I
I'm gonna tribute it to Easter Sunday
right now but if it's not because of
that it's disheartening it it's
disheartening and again if it's because
of that for some people longer god but
here's the thing here's the English I'm
a quadruped then we'll finish it up we
move on
um and we got a lot of addict in it but
I want to comment specifically because
of that because at the end of the day
that mentality like you said that's not
what God is here like I said what are us
all together is gaming we having a good
time we gonna have some fun that's what
it's about and this whole clique
mentality stuff like truth be told like
Lord Alex smoked I said my that's my
brother from another mother if I was to
apply the same entirely that I see out
here in the social media to Twitter and
what's going on me and him wouldn't be
friends cuz so many people told me y'all
don't mess with him don't use it and
that ended up being one of my coolest
and best friends Evan we can tell me I
[Laughter]
could be able to develop one of the best
friendships I've had you know over the
last two years and ain't nobody gonna
tell me about that man right there so
you already know what it is Lord addict
if you have to make your friendship with
somebody else contingent on their
friendship with somebody all you facts
you need to reevaluate whatever
friendship and see you absolutely need
to press the reset button
finishing sign because we go move over
go get into these games and a lot of fun
so of course it is I himself alright I
go get a tiki torch Christmas we are
here name an hour
black belt gaming that telly with you
buddy here but what you need to hit so
before we get into what the Lord's are
playing this week I want to start off
with Lord Stan his video game system
history his single of his journey and IT
and as a journalist in the video game
industry for over 15 years and of course
would let him to the creation of the
amazing and LG Park blush in front of
men but cry up in here man come on with
videogame systems and the arcade what
did you start oh my goodness so I
started probably when I was seven and so
I was born in the 70s our actually I
started off probably with my father
brought home of vic-20 once lunar lander
that was my problem my first game ever
Wow I played stuff like TI 99 for a
little um pac-man clone called munch man
it was exact you know stuff like that
and then um I had tari 2600 I grew up on
Atari mmm not just the 2600 I've had the
Atari computer systems and a lot gran a
BBS an old bulletin board system on an
Atari yeah very impressive
so my venture into my love of Sega
though came by total accident
so really yeah so I had gone through
Johan Atari had the actually also had an
Intellivision which
turned out to be the system that I
really liked more mm-hmm and I went from
there
got a cleco vision the clear vision was
unbelievable to this day to this day I
will still play that because our system
and then you had the you had the wheel
the first time is the first real system
that had had that had a steering wheel
played in there go on to become turbo
yes yes classic and then it had the this
to show you how cross play happened back
then it had an expansion slot on the
front and legislature Atari 2600 games
yes you think a lot of this stuff
happened happened recently but man we
had voice back in the Intellivision days
we had you know we had not over IP you
had a little cartoon team bomber that
kind of so as we as we as I went on and
went on and went on after after Nintendo
came out I really wanted an NES really
wanted it NES so Hanukkah rolls around
my father brings home a Sega Genesis mmm
I was devastated devastated absolutely
devastated I wanted I wanted Nintendo
was the thing I wanted in Tendo and I
was just angry and I was like it was
like how could you do this to me like
you know it's like it's like you want
something and your dad brings home the
knockoff like that you know one quick
question I get it because as a kid I
know you want it what you want it but
also did you at least impressed
graphically so all right so let me
finish my next sentence okay
I my father was like well just try it so
we so we did we hooked it up got it
hooked up and the pack in game at that
point gentlemen was altered beast
Altered Beast turned it on hit start
heard rise runs rain I was like whoa
altered beast I forgot Nintendo existed
there was nothing from that point on
that Nintendo could do I was and and I
and and as I got a little older I worked
for what's now Game Stop used to be
called games and gadgets and then called
Electronics Boutique booty yeah no I
worked there you want to talk about the
biggest Sega fanboy warrior I would man
I would get an arguments of you and your
Street Fighter I got Mortal Kombat [ __ ]
it was it was I was horrible that's why
I hate what's going on now cuz I
remember what it was like being that
horrible
I was so I mean I stay at CD my gun and
I still got my collection my 32x
collection and then the Saturn and then
the Dreamcast yeah and it I I sit and
and once in a while just ponder what
happened to Sega I know what happened I
got the sadder I got what happened you
know I understand the mistakes they made
with a Saturn because I was in them
because I was in retail at the time I
was you know I was in that in the sales
cycle of that so I understood it's not
to put their Dreamcast was man I've you
know in this day and age you went from
the ps3 making the mistakes that they
made to Sony being able to completely
bounce back with the ps4
daga didn't have that opportunity they
brought out a system with the Dreamcast
that pioneered so much what we play
today and they never got the chance to
get past that to get past the Saturn and
it's so sad to see because it's the
system was so it was such a phenomenal
system there's so many things they did
right and then that like we I know we
went back and forth what it went to it a
little bit well you made me really that
launch lineup was a basic plate
untouched to this day and I really
because I mean us Legolas I saw at that
sound like me at us thing was going at
it I was just like that was really
impressed with it with the switch line I
lost things like go back in the crazy
you have to because you when you
understand what anal games it games that
you haven't even seen redone by other
developers like Power Stone I mean that
game that game was so revolutionary in
so many ways that was Capcom's heyday
you know yes you know just Skies of
Arcadia was a launch title on launch
title a large title
what was was NASA to the to the
roundtable was crazy taxi at launch oh
no no stinger was launched skies came
afterwards these games are so epic is
because a lot of these games wait to the
install base is built learning
one date because they knew they needed
it the difference was is they knew they
needed eight they really soured
everybody with the Saturn to the extent
that you know KB toy and Hobby didn't
sell it they needed they needed that
launch lineup but then I guess they
weren't just thrown together games
either we're talking about NFL 2k blip
blitz was Sonic Adventure was in that
lineup
games you had like focus in racer or
like yep you had Kart and you had Monaco
Grand Prix
heart heart flag-to-flag was nothing to
sleep on either yes you had air force
Delta that was kind of Konami first you
know shot over it at making something to
take on air combat combat rather you had
a mortal kombat game at launch and you
had Hydro Thunder which turns out to be
a game that that would launch kind of
the the semi career one of my more
favorite indie developers vector unit
then they bought that they when
Microsoft bought the Hydra Thunder IP
Midway when Midway tanked
they got vector unit to make the Hydra
sunder hurricane which was an Xbox 360
game and that launched them into beach
buggy racing Riptide GP and now they're
bringing out another beach buggy racing
game and so you know these I'm telling
you man
Sega had such a hand in sin what happens
god what has happened coming forward and
people sometimes because gaming has
become so mainstream now a lot of young
people are gamers that didn't get
started until the ps2 ps3 Xbox Xbox 360
[Laughter]
you don't get a chance sometimes they
don't get a chance to or they don't get
the opportunity to understand where some
of this stuff came from
you know they don't get the chance to
understand the first console that really
had a broadband adapter on it yes was
the dream came cast absolutely was it
was a 14-4 33:6 I don't remember was a
33:6 was a 56k modem in it but there was
an actual Ethernet broadband adapter
that you you are correct and you drop it
somebody somebody's now is about the
chattel of you right now
they had another game ripping Raiders
ripping riders which one of Ned now I'm
blanking PlayStation had it they were it
was a playstation snowboarding franchise
and a cool boarders cool born folks we
make cool boarders they couldn't bring
cool boarders over to the Dreamcast
because of the IP so he made a game
called ribbon riders and was mostly
identical we had they had stuff like
that vanishing point will scz dog see
metropolis tree these guys that was the
precursor frog thing because um in
reference to the importance of that that
line of new-looking are saying about how
like big that Dream Castle on it was
because of what happened with the Saturn
and truth be told and I'm a Sega kid
like when solving a kid got the sad
I got a soured like I was kinda like I'm
not feeling it so the Dreamcast was kind
of like that reinvigoration that Sega
was back like it was like in a big way
and obviously we cannot forget the shirt
that you have on right bring I'll bring
the camera forward a little bit go let's
go like when I first saw these and Rio
was fight his pops was in a row and
entered what was so I'll never forget
I'm sorry I'm didn't mean cut you off
I'm sorry you got me all sad let's go
I actually so let me um let me segue it
by saying that my first game journalism
job was actually with a Dreamcast
website so you know I got out of I got
out of working at EB and stuff like that
kind of got into I'm also a musician so
I started working for music shops and I
ended up making a what turns out to be
one of the most interesting choices of
my life I decided to work for a piano
sale shop well I could tell you pianos
are not an impulse buy I could go weeks
without seeing a human being
so I started bringing my Saturn into the
shop and hooking it up to the monitor
because I had the ability to do that so
I'm sitting there playing you know Sega
Rally and stuff like that and they had a
56k modem hooked up to the computer
there that we would use to dial in to
the main office and whatnot so I started
I started like looking around the
internet for four Sega information and
ran across this guy who was building a
site for a new console say goes working
on and so I don't remember how it
happened but I got involved with it and
became a writer for this guy kind of
pulling news and things like that and
and then the Dreamcast was officially
kind of announced and at e3 that year
they were gonna they were gonna you know
it off so somehow I found a number for
somebody at Sega who got me in touch
with Sega's PR company and got us
registered as media for e3 nine years
and it was amazing I I was young so I
didn't have a family I didn't have to
worry about leave kids home so yeah I
would jump on a plane go to go to go to
this show and I remember walking around
the Sega booth and I stopped at this
display and there was an old man
face on the play and they were
manipulating his face to make him make
his eyebrows raised to make him smile to
make him frown - hmm - manipulate and it
was a concept video for Shenmue mm and I
must have it was one of the two times
that I've that I that something has
stopped me at the ships tracks in my
tracks to just stare at mmm
I'll give you the other one you guys are
like this okay the next year right
before launch this its launch year 99
mm-hmm and they're showing off the
launch lineup on the screen and the
screens up high so you know you look up
kinda you see them kind of dangling from
the from ceiling and stuff like that and
I'm walking through the booth and and I
look up and they're showing off NFL 2k
mm the quarterback throws the ball and
what I'm seeing is the receivers running
downfield now we've seen this in Madden
every year we've seen the other I sold
the receiver turn his head and turn to
catch the ball yes he stopped I stop and
watch that screen for another 20 minutes
gone oh my my god I so Shenmue kind of
hit me in that same way yes and then as
I began to see what this game unfolded
it took over my life while I played it
was it was absolutely revolutionary and
like you know we talked about it many
IOPS ad nauseam but people don't realize
at that time the things that you're
saying just the way the Fertile Grassley
how the game look and correct me if I'm
wrong was that the a.m. to engine that
um you Suzuki these guys were using it
look very similar to like the virtue
fighters engine it but refined I was in
an open world kind of a sense I don't
remember
I know that am too public have developed
it I don't know what engine he used
honestly and it's been so so long
whatever that engine was but it was
spectacular and you got the open world
aspect the real-time aspect you could go
get a job and young for me the cherry on
the sundae I'll never forget Lord King
takes me shows me where the time are
yeah I'm like alright and then they have
like an a hang on display a space Harry
display and I'm like he's like I'm like
you complain okay and I jumped and they
will fully arcade replicated versions
perfect emulation and I'm sitting and
I'm playing hang on in the music of Zod
and I'm going crazy I'm like I'm
literally in the arcade of a game
playing a game this is ridiculous the
game was was truly out of his time
I don't know Suzuki sound blew the
budget that game was somewhere home
where necessity or something like that
it was a crazy budget for that game um
it is not the budget for the current
game I can tell you that I there are
games that are special that is a special
game and I love to see a lot of folks
who are looking for remasters of those
and who are or looking at at the third
one because it it shows that there's
still some passion for that series and
for what you Suzuki and Masahiro
Yoshimoto put into that game it's not
just that man the soundtrack soundtrack
the soundtrack was that was a there was
a it was a it was a user kashiro I
believe I mean I was just you know it
brought to the game brought you in
world mm-hmm like game didn't do in that
day we were intrigued because everybody
had driving did on Saturday on Channel
five and you know Shaw Brothers
shout-out to the Shaw Brothers Shawn
Rodney Shaw who brought us these
wonderful movies like five deadly venoms
classic these movies were our way into
the Orient okay so now they brought us a
game was one around and the karate the
QuickTime events the Evergreen that game
was so rich it was beautiful
and it also gave us another Avenue into
what a culture that was mystifying us
but also bringing us up in walking over
to our childhood so that's why I really
believe that game was so huge is because
it gave us a peek in to what we was most
curious about and what we really wanted
to be about and it was great and it was
done perfectly yeah that's a good point
game that's a good point ade it
definitely opened us up to uh Eastern
culture and just like it just it was
just so well done it truly was ahead of
its time and it's good to see that you
know hopefully this remaster I mean hope
you know remasters come out before the
new one that'll be great
but never coming out all right this fine
we got to see what's going on with so I
mean I jerk but they do have a publisher
so I mean Deep Silver is publishing it
now of course owned by THQ Nordic Nordic
so I I'm confident the game is going to
get an influx of the money it needs to
finish there's no way
but when you have one the original game
when the original game has has a 70
million dollar budget and this game has
a six million dollar budget yeah saying
he had to he had to my first memory of
meeting Peter Moore was at a an e3 party
that Sega Sagan knew how to do that
stuff up rent it out they rented out a
an industrial complex and had girders
and all this stuff in this big giant
screen where they had I can't remember
who the basketball player was who was
playing NBA 2k and um and I'm telling
you band of he's up on a girder one of
my flirt let me tell you one of my
absolute favorite in the industry let me
tell you it's funny you say that that's
how me and you I know you're my brother
from another mother
toothless thing because tell me this
tell me that Peter Moore understood how
to present how to make it an event a
show his enthusiasm was so evident in
everything he did and it was just cool
to see even from the saiga transition to
the Xbox transition he even talked about
he was just like hey man you know I had
the rivalry against two places because
what they did to my beloved yeah he
stood up on this girder on a girder with
no protection nothing underneath of him
yelling to the crowd we are gonna kick
Tony's ass and the crowd went berserk
because of course you know it's we're
all Sega fans were all there for you
know and but this was the mentality this
is the guy who rolled who this is the
guy who who
knew so much that people wanted a halo -
release date said he had that thing
tattoo time tomorrow and went and I've
got a picture of it somewhere that I
gotta go find where he rolled his sleeve
up and he is man was not badly built and
there it is and for a long time people
have speculated whether or not it's real
or not because the following year for
Xbox he rolled up his other sleeve and
he had a grand theft auto that one was
you could tell that one was totally fake
Natalie works for Liverpool Liverpool
Football Club I think I think it's okay
if everybody knows at that halo tattoo
Israel I have seen it up close yeah one
of the reasons that that I had so much
respect for Peter Moores not only did he
understand what was needed to get third
parties to to Sega and to Xbox and to
get you know a kind of where they were
going before he left but he knew he knew
how to how to deal with people mm-hmm
and one of the things that I will always
take away from my time going to three
every year and and and you know kind of
being in that that that industry is I
you know you never have fun at e3 if
you're a journalist you just don't you
do your meeting after meeting after
meeting after meeting after meeting I
don't think I ever spent more than 10 or
15 minutes actually playing a game
playing games on the floor I wa it was
it was always on the go on the go and
these guys to you know it's not just us
as journalists these executives got to
meet with us they've got to meet with
retail they've got to meet was a ton of
different people so I would always be up
in the Microsoft booth getting ready for
my meeting talking to my to my rep a
shout out to my man
Arnie Meyer who by the way now
PR the PR head for Naughty Dog also a
fantastic human being he's kind of one
of the reasons that
nlg even exists to be quite honest with
you assuming it's one of the reasons I
that I have a lot of respect and love
for Microsoft they are a big reason that
I was able to do what I was able to do
so you know Peter Moore would always be
floating around cuz he's got tons of
meetings things like that there was not
a year gone by where he didn't walk up
to me even if it was just for a second
knew he had to go somewhere else said
hey Mike how you doing how's the family
shook hands hope everything's well hey
man I gotta run but I just want to stop
and say hello so that it's who Peter
Moore was and I said that that's what a
that's what a leader does mm-hmm I mean
you yeah you could be taking us back and
in completely I mean I'm a huge PETA
more fan and a lot of a lot of young
people and uh it was just good to see
that aggressiveness translate his
passion always translated and those are
good times ready to say good times it
through the Xbox the early OG xbox error
and stuff like that and 360 really
really cool stuff to see and just to see
that aggressive and a lot of people who
are Xbox fan kind of miss that sometimes
you gotta miss that aggression ated that
that love you know so is there a reason
there's a reason that man wherever that
man went that company he was with
succeeded that or before that when he
was Reebok yeah it doesn't matter you
know he guided EA into a pretty good
spot yes
you know they're not the greatest spot
at the moment just want to transition
you now as far as the industry I know
you've been in the game for some time
staying so like you what was the start
for the transition of it's now becoming
a hobby or something a passion that you
love playing these games to actually
getting your foot in the industry and as
a journalist it had to have been III
just an understanding that
when I talk to people about you know the
games in the gaming industry that they
when I was a writer for for Dreamcast HQ
Sega took us seriously there weren't
many sites out there that were covering
a Dreamcast and and you know there
really wasn't a polar information yet of
the big sites you know that we were
still in we were still in sort of kind
of a transition out of the magazine era
and so when when Sega decided to stop
making a Dreamcast it was a I had one of
two ways I could go I could just be done
get back to you know what I was doing or
I felt like we had made some track I'd
made some traction I had friends in the
industry that I was making why not make
a go at a multi-platform site if Sega's
gonna do it why couldn't we and so a
couple of guys that I had met on
dreamcast HQ I broached the subject of
hey why don't we why don't we take a
shot at at creating a site that'll just
cover every place Sega's going they're
gonna they're gonna put their stuff on
the Xbox they're gonna put the stuff on
the PlayStation I'm gonna put their
stuff on Nintendo's console why don't we
uh why don't we move along with it
evolution yeah and so I there was a guy
who oversees that helped kind of design
the first site wrote kind of a back end
for us we started populating information
all of a sudden people started actually
coming to it mm-hmm
and we still had great ties with Sega so
Sega was still sending us nice product
and we we incorporated which was one of
the big things you had to do to go to e3
if you wanted to be an e3 the it wasn't
quite as tough as like getting into
packs now late to get into packs you
have to basically forego
your firstborn yeah I know as I'm
excited for you that that take is going
a pax man I live I live vicariously
through half a tick through you guys
through Sam through the anchorman I live
through you guys cuz what you guys do is
the right way and what you guys do is is
like Sam
I've watched I've read some of his
always reviews that's what I call him
he's yeah he he reminds me of the way I
used to write and I just I can't I
cannot speak highly enough of that man
and what's and what he is doing
so Reena Bob yeah so anyway we went
through a period where we were growing
and companies were starting to pay
attention to us and then we got in with
yugioh networks became an affiliate and
when that happened Microsoft and Sony
began to really pay attention to us
mm-hmm which is why I credit you know
there was a also the second time I met
Peter Moore was a launch a neat Xbox 360
launch in New York we went up a bunch of
us went up met my rep sat down played
some games and actually had dinner with
Peter and I talked and and then all of a
sudden I'm getting a form in the mail
for debug Xbox which is this time was
how you did preview stuff they sent you
gold yes they send you these red discs
and green discs yeah you had I still
have it I still have the D bugs that
never sent it back and I never asked for
it I can't use it because it's it's
totally unusable but I have it as a
memento
and I'm like guys we're we're gonna be
previewing games and what did that
happen
EA and Konami and cab companies guys
like
right you have a debug you know oh great
because it's cheaper to send you review
code and the send me product like I
don't care and then what and we went to
Sony and said hey guys look we're
previewing Xbox stuff we're
multi-platform we want to preview your
stuff too and it took them knowing that
we that that was happening for them to
go oh yeah yeah absolutely and so doing
know a company who has always sucked
with PRS Nintendo it all they know Liz
Harris I still wake up in a cold sweat
here in it but you know and I credit I
credit Microsoft for us surviving
against onion GameSpot I mean those were
the those were the the big Titans at the
time and we held our own for many years
again so obviously you know they were
the kings of the castles but we were
pulling in one to two million talk to
numbers I back then you needed it that's
what you know now it's all about
subscribers and views and stuff back
then it was how many people hit your
site and we had some because of that we
had some really good experiences I you
know I loved reminiscing about what's
happened to me in the gaming industry
because it's it there are things that
that I get to pass down to my kids
there's things that that I'm proud of
then that we used to do back before all
this nonsense and Twitter and you know
I've got I've got but I've got two box
quotes to my name I've got I've got
interviews with the remember remember
Dan Stevens and Peter O'Keefe from the
vase I've got a I've got a great
interview with them that I did I got to
talk to people I never would have talked
to and something that I will never
forget in my life I'm a I'm a relief
pitcher for an unlockable game at MLB
2k7 I mean these are the I was just
about to ask
heard rumors that you were in a game
what game and so the story goes I'll
make this very quick because we haven't
even come to our topic
I love you guys seriously um I I got so
close to to my friends at 2k 2k and 2k
sports - yay games my rep called me one
day and says I can't tell you why I just
need just I just did something I need
from you and I need you to say yes
I said well what I do please don't make
me tell you just tell me it's okay to do
it and I'm like oh come on man
so I said all right fine so you said so
he must have pulled a picture of me from
somewhere and and later on he never
mentioned it for like half a year or so
and next thing you know MLB to cake um
zout to k7 comes out he said Louis on
favorite I get a review copy and a note
and it says Mike I need you to put this
code in unlock everything and I need you
to go to to 1988 LA Dodgers and I need
you to play a game with them and so I'm
like alright fine so I fired it up
unlocked it and I'm picking my team I
get to the pitchers and I called him I
said you son of a [ __ ] hey he just
started to laugh he said surprise
I'm like oh my I said are you kidding me
he said Oh
play it so don't just don't just look
play get it and it had like a it didn't
have my exact picture but it had a I'm
looking for it on Facebook while I'm
talking
it had a like a like scenario go do
everything and he's like no keep going
so so I picked them as a starting
pitcher even though I did
apparently I have no stamina sovereign
if you if you want to check it out it's
fine but don't don't start
me I might not get past the third inning
so I started the game and as I'm playing
when it when when I'm when I hit the
mound John Miller says my name whoa I
put the controller down and when I went
to bat and the and the the the stadium
announcer and it says my name correctly
it's not even I mean it's like did
somebody somebody told them what my name
was and and John Miller and the stadium
announcer say my name and I was like I
was so overwhelmed like that's no it is
something and in case anybody you know
wants to try to find it themselves it
doesn't matter which platform it's on so
it's not like a downloadable which is it
which one it's 2 K 7 K 7 okay before
either honestly I was so overwhelmed
with with gratitude I mean I just it was
it was nothing that I felt like I
deserved I you know I was like just
doing my job he's like well you are you
know he's like is you you you you do
such a good job that this is what we
wanted to do free of us I'm like I just
I just like think I don't deserve this I
mean just I I was so order last minute
you were more than this I find it I'll
share soon as I find enough you know I
just you know so those are those are
memories that I've had I've had great
memories of interviews with people I've
actually met the guy who was the voice
of Space Ghost Coast to Coast
yeah you know
I've just those are the things that I
remember and it all culminated around
you know I had a I had a mentality of
you be fair you be objective you know
nowadays and and this is what this is
what has always this is what's troubled
me about the about the gaming journalism
of today everybody has to write their
news and then put some sort of
commentary on it from their point of
view or their you know their personal
you know when we when we wrote a news
article I damn near just cut and pasted
the press release mmm because all I
wanted to do was show the person or the
whoever was watching I just wanted to
show them what the company had to say
and let them make up their own mind as
to how they felt about it now obviously
I reviewed games so I had I had a
subjectivity to that of course you would
you're reviewing games that that is one
thing that you can't do semi objective
is gonna be some opinion but when you
are reporting the news that is what
you're supposed to do and that's what I
like about that's what I like about Sam
and what tick is doing is it's just
report it and let people decide for
themselves how they feel about it
whether it's good bad or indifferent
that's for the person to interpret on
their own
and so I that's that's something I
always espouse to it may be that maybe
that's what garnered so much of that
from companies is that I wouldn't I
wouldn't go out of my way to to trash
something or to you know or to be super
negative right I just couldn't do it if
it was negative stuff I report here it
is I reported about it but I didn't I
didn't put my spin on it objectivity man
that's what it's all about at the end of
the day and when I what I've seen people
say you know objectivity
you know you there's no such thing or
there's no yeah see
hi I wholly reject that ah here you go
no I don't know where he got this
picture from but it does have the goat
and the mustache let's see it oh you
have to click on me there cuz I'm
sharing it's one of my pride and Joy's
nice I remember that whole you I to look
at the u.s. wasn't to k7 the one with
the crazy wind effects like they like
the jerseys would blow in the wind and
we all lost our mind over that start and
that's started that's started with MBA
remember the hole remember the hole you
could you could you know the jerseys
moved independently of the bodies that
were all that started from absolutely
great memories man I this is what
happens this happens every time I come
on a show for our show we go we go we go
power throw we go bad I just got that's
fine reference to obviously energy and
um the creation those guys your crew got
crazy Wong htk was a viper strike and it
was mad girls yes yes so just what then
led after the I mean you still doing the
site and everything but then what led to
the actual podcast creation so I retired
from the site in 2007 when my first my
oldest son got a little too old and
needed a little too much attention for
me to do a full-time job plus a web site
so I gave it up still played a bit then
I kind of got out of gaming for a for a
bit for about
years 2013 rolls around and Microsoft
and Sony are getting raid debut new
consoles and I start to get a little
little interested in like you know it's
been a while busted out my 360 busted
out my ps3 got back got myself back into
it and then thought to myself well you
know what if I brought nlg back what if
I brought the brand back what if I did
something with it and so I got with a
couple of my original writers from from
the site and said well what do we want
to do and they're like well I can't do a
site anymore I mean we can't put that
much time into it but I see all these
other people doing YouTube videos and
podcasts why don't we try like a weekly
podcast well we'll record it I'll edit
it will you know we started out doing
like Skype but I would but I recorded it
and then we died I edit it cleaning it
up and then put it out on YouTube it's
not you after a couple of weeks they
couldn't do it because lie you know
their lives were a little too busy so I
was like you know I I kind of like this
so I started getting you know some
people in and out and then about two
years ago I had a unfortunate
falling-out with one of my longtime
friends who was also podcasting with us
and so I was almost close to doing the
show by myself and Frankie aler who is
viper strike from short hauls gaming
said now he was like nah man I'll come
in and do a couple shows with you and
and help you out so he came on we did a
couple of shows that he like really
enjoyed himself so from there HD came
Peter and and another gentleman Jason
they were in our chat and they were like
hey man come guest on your show and so I
had Peter on Jason on and Peter's been
on now for two to nine almost two and a
half years it'll be exactly if at e3
this III think he
all been on three years I think chef ACK
and so Frankie I you know when when I
lost my friend and and I and I lost my
my co-host
I almost shut it down it's like yeah you
can't do that and I couldn't I was like
really upset and Frankie kind of saved
me like I credit Frankie for for
literally the reason that then the
podcast is alive today and it Juan came
along and you know his passion was he
loved retro stuff I see it with he is
our he's you know Peter and Frankie and
I are all multi-platinum ulty plaque guy
he's our xbox guys out about our xbox
guy he owns a switch he loves his switch
but he loves his Xbox nothing wrong with
that at all
you know but he also has this love of
retro gaming so you know we were trying
to think of things to do because
everybody comes on and talks and does
stuff we just didn't want to be another
talking podcast where we're we're in a
were a little fish in a big bowl so
we're like man what could we do this a
little different he said well I could I
could bring up a retro game and we could
talk about it I'm like wow that sounds
like a great idea we'll call it Juan's
retro recommendation and that's started
he's this is uh I think he is on our
nearly if it's not our 40th he's coming
up on our 40th retro rec the next
podcast and it ranges anything from
PlayStation 1 to Xbox Genesis super
nintendo nes he's got a wife around I
watch and I'm like wow he's taking him
back like I said he had the original
Tekken photo of ps1 on yeah he also here
the original Tekken he had the original
Gran Turismo
yes you know I know he's a force a guy
now but back then he was a big grant
Teresa was the main factor yeah myself
away from Sega GT long enough to play
Teresa but you know these guys these
guys bring they bring variety they bring
an ability to they bring knowledge and
that's what I like you know I I what
it's amazing to me the some of the
knowledge that that they have and what
they can what they can bring to to the
gamers as far as information goes you
know we all we all debate once in a
while too there are things that I don't
often you know there's times when I
disagree with these guys they disagree
with me and we have some great debates
some great discussions smoothies you
guys well I'm gonna play this I'm gonna
play this thing back like seven or eight
times to try to figure out how to make
my intros as smooth as hi everybody
oh my god I am as white as the trivet I
but you know you know seriousness these
guys bring with them different different
skill set different knowledge base and
but they all have gaming passion passion
you see it yes absolutely and I love
that and we pride ourselves on making
sure that we stay focused on games we
stay focused on the industry we we don't
I say this politely
yeah we we try to say like even at the
bill there were earlier times when you
know a guest or two would name drop
someone and I'd hit them in the chat hey
man we don't do that here you know and
and so this just we take the we take
enough pride in what we do
that we want to we want to be we want to
be the group you come to when you want
to get away from that like il pay you're
going to get away from that nephews on
the ILP and I'm gonna kick you come the
nlg it's that and I call it the
three-letter podcast a good point
because the end of the day when I when I
use the figurative terminal room it's
like you said it's it's the escape from
all the outside noise of the world and
that's what King knows it's off no Zach
no like everyone's got so much going on
in life and I hope is just a reflection
of the Saturday's that we used to have
in the house and it was just all yeah
all our friends
it was just gaming it was just fun
that's all it was about and you got to
get away from your normal drama of life
and what one of the things we did at the
beginning of the year is we made the
conscious decision to move ourselves
from YouTube to twitch for two reasons
number one we found the quality of video
on twitch because we do a Skype and an
xsplit broadcast so you know I I'm
humbled I was humbled earlier when you
talked about our production value it's
not nearly what I've seen other people
do but we take a lot of pride in how
we're developing our site and how we're
doing video and giving Wan his space for
his retro wreck so that it it looks
professional and twitch gives us so much
better video quality than YouTube but it
also puts us in front of a different
audience it puts us a ton of people who
are streaming games who are playing
games who I want to come see us to see a
gaming show not a not a [ __ ] fest with
seven people yelling at each other and
talking about how you know console X
sucks and this person sucks and this guy
is a horrible per you know I just like I
I can't I can't do it and I don't have
the time or the patience for it so going
to go into twitch being here in the
realm you know these are the places I
want to be this is this is my this is
where is where my gaming life and much
of we glad to
every man is long overdue long overdue
just hearing those though that history
was a lot of feels stuff real quick um
loss of Lord King what have you guys
been playing this week I was gonna touch
anything this week specifically let's
start with lo saw so I couldn't play our
way out with King couldn't play any see
at the yesterday was my plan to play
like I said wife you folded that so that
was that you know anything I managed to
download was punch out on the eShop I
was ask you about that loss loss I'm
surprised Nintendo allowed that yummy
this is Lauren right it hasn't really
been reproduced anywhere and you know
it's always cool punch out I don't know
if they plan to add it or if it has at
this point that online functionality
they were talking about with all their
games bro like the oldest stuff that's
going to be rolled into the service so I
all I've done was play a little bit and
old-school punch-out reminds me more of
like super punch-out than it does my
taxes I agree um you know you have the
the wireframe incredible character no
Little Mac yeah and it's different like
the game feels different it's not as
much about the boxing technique as it is
about finding patterns and like getting
your super up so you can just bash them
you know with the super punches and
whatnot so it's just it's cool to play
because I have a lot of memories playing
that game is this a store like right
down the street from where I grew up
that I used to go in all the time to
play and it was like it wasn't a quarter
I think was like 50 or 70 yeah that was
an expensive one I remember that one
yeah so it was cool to have it on the go
so that that's it all my bad news I
think got delayed later 35 year old game
badly like bad dudes versus yes it's a
good tempo Esau Lord King would have you
could play this week
[Laughter]
I play I played on some doom on the
check the patch I played also do you
know what's crazy a shout-out to lo
cradles a week before I was playing doom
and I was like man it'd be crazy if they
could get this up to the 4k because it
look like Vasiliy he was mad on my
screen wow great and then lo and behold
like and then it was coming off the next
week so I was really looking forward to
that and then I played a little bit of
what was that Call of Duty it was the
new downloadable
one of those ones that my boy Mason
that's always bothering me to play it
became backwardly compatible shout out
the cradles again for the backwardly
compatible i played it on backwards
compatible and I'm loving the fact that
you know Microsoft has allowed me to
play current gen um you know a past
generation and these future games that
are coming out that are 4k you know 60
frames per second and I'm just loving
the whole ecosphere of what's going on
right now that your dollar is really
stretching it's like really stretching
my buck has with such a long way that I
don't have to go buy a game like you
just said I'm bad dude right I went to
be crazy if they were like Oh bad news
is backwardly compatible just know
inside the shop and just play it and I
was just blowing my mind this week dead
I was playing such a wide variety of
games from so many different eras good
time good time real quick before going
on this morning I was able to play
little bit of something right so Lord
Lord shallow just consuming I was trying
to hold off but yes I saw the digital
foundry break down so I got to play
through the intro intro part when I tell
you that that game 4k HDR oh my lord the
things they've done with that engine
like I'm sure I'm sure like on the PC
side it's ridiculous but remember on the
PC you're not gonna find HDR it's gonna
be difficult to get a C on a PC with a
PC monitor so the HDR is always gonna be
the game changer on a 4k HDR TV that
game looks absolutely spectacular like a
man
it runs beautifully like all the full
Foley it's like it really has me excited
for redneck honestly like read dad's
gonna do these two games are absolutely
ridiculous that was the main reason some
I couldn't do the arm I mean what we
need to be talking about the doom thing
like I could I couldn't do to do much
because I was I knew that patch was
covered and now and I'm like oh man but
shot the Sinister he was like don't
worry I'm doing my due diligence on the
game [ __ ] I got you I saw for crab just
been pretty much on my timeline and I
finally finished XCOM - oh my god
fantastic fantastic that's my favorite
artists of all time and like I love me
some ex-cop so in the ending was great
love the new factions new systems they
open the door for XCOM dream
early maryland developers represent oh
yeah oh that's kind of miraculous from
me Oh Ashley you'll love this that you
like Dexcom move it so I recently did a
community theater production of The
Music Man
and the head guy the guy who played the
lead role worked on a game mm they have
it they have a game coming he wasn't
allowed to tell me about that's my game
I had so much fun with that obviously I
do some washout he bounces the fast
update as around for destiny - we got
flash point number 10 out there on the
ILP channel you can check that out with
you with the intense breakdown when
loading Bonta so having fun baby steps
in the right direction and I just want
to shout I want to go quick any
spotlight shout out to my guys my polish
Lords over that tape media they sent me
a review copy of our urban trial
playground for the Nintendo switch and
um yourself you know what it reminds me
of a king also remember this to remember
California games for the Atari Lynx oh
my god it's like it was just a BMX
portion like this shades of that with
the tricks and the bike and you sitting
there falling off the bike I can only
funny ways I know but they were surfing
it was skateboarding skateboard
skateboard down that down the sidewalk
and not trip over stuff yes I was like
the links launch title so I want to give
out my chance over there at 8 media for
replicating that fear I believe the game
comes out on actually comes out it's
Tuesday if she comes out on the fifth
something like that so I'll be able to
look I have your fan of on that style
California games being metric
like that kind of stuff so while anyway
you're gonna get to poll last week's
poll jokes in the people have spoken to
the question with the recent release of
CFDs and the rise of more games as a
service should developers be held
accountable when initial launch content
might be considered minimal the winner
at 59% in a threeway ILP poll was that
no no content equals the games as a
service game is unfinished second place
at 27% was the games as a service is an
evolving game group and third place at
14% are shallows I don't care as long as
it's $10 in game past group what do you
think about this oh my god tired right
here just because the game doesn't have
enough content for you doesn't mean it
doesn't have enough content for others
and that you and I get it if if this
game is not for you because it doesn't
have enough content I get it it's it's
perfectly fine
I know people who won't play Madden
anymore because they feel it's the same
game every year it is that's that's the
logical it's okay it's perfectly okay
but it doesn't necessarily work comments
I see I've seen this game should be an
earth should be in early access right
now stop stop it stop it stop look stop
the game should the game is is not
broken the game is not unfinished
mmm-hmm if you want to have a discussion
about whether or not there's enough
content that's fine but there are a lot
of people there is a reason that it's
leading sales in Europe in Australia and
it's likely gonna show up on a MPD's
next
there's a reason for it yeah because
it's for a lot of people it's a starting
point mm-hmm and for a lot of people
there's enough content right now that as
long as as long as they know there's a
road map and and RAIR has said that
rares on your channel so they've you
know they've talked to you guys about
this this this the game right now is
just a ton of fun with friends even if
it's repetitive it's still a ton of fun
and we've discussed before like how do
you equate fun you know when people are
people are saying it's less content
versus people who are actually enjoying
the game and saying that they are having
fun can you negate that aspect and
that's why I said it's one of the most
polarizing games because shouldn't be
able to you shouldn't be able to cuz if
there's a group that is legitimately
saying I am enjoying every aspect of
this game then it's it's accomplished
what it needed to accomplish okay in the
sales look like it's reflecting what
you're saying you know those thing yeah
and I mean you know and I want to bring
up a point cuz I like I do like watching
the chatroom and irrelevant natives
bring up he says objectively it doesn't
have enough content to boot however for
some it's fine but that that that in and
of itself makes that not objective for
but
I believe they call it the Xbox one
all-in-one entertainment system okay I I
do understand look it's the game and I'm
not saying that the game does not need
more content I'm not saying that I'm not
saying that as it stands right now three
months down the line if there's nothing
new that they're not going to bleed bass
I'm not saying that what I'm saying is
is that they have two million people
playing this game and probably more by
now they have that based upon what they
launched yes you have to you have to
understand it that is impressive no
matter what I don't care how many people
bought it versus how many people are
using it on game pass because remember
game pass makes them money - it's ten
dollars now and then ten dollars and
then ten dollars and then ten dollars
they're gonna make their money on these
leaves no doubt absolutely that's that's
a totally agree we go on for Lord solve
we got to get this show rolling
we had somebody started a Oh totally not
it's all good lusting don't worry about
it so we gonna get this uh with the
sunrays it's I'm going over and raise
this happening to many people with my
but I'm gonna quickly I mean when it
comes to games graphics this past
generation um we've reached a point in
graphics where it hasn't stagnated but
it's difficult for a big developer to
make a bad looking game you have to go
out of your way to make a bad looking
game so and you the talk is always you
know what's the next step right um with
you know psvr that's a you know it's a
different route that some people have
taken in terms of expanding what what
video games can be right in terms of
graphics we haven't seen that big jump
that we saw when we saw from 8-bit
16-bit 16-bit two polygons mom and we've
we've always been looking like what's
the next step right so for a long time
it's been rate racing right so the idea
of ray tracing is that you take what
what ray tracing does is it renders a 3d
object on the fly you know in the moment
um taking into account everything that
could be affecting it in the Arab in the
surrounding environment so it takes into
account lighting it takes into account
reflections it takes into account
shadows and positioning and it does this
all real-time so what it does is present
a very lifelike image now the problem
with this is like I just mentioned this
it has to happen real time so it it's
never really been something that's
viable for gaming in this day and age
right gaming in this day and age is
rendered in what's in something what
they call rasterization rasterization is
a technique that basically takes 3d
information and makes it 2d to be
displayed on your screen right and then
all the shadow information reflection
information all that stuff is added
afterwards right so the problem with
that is that though it makes
easier for the systems that we have in
own today to be able to do that um it
requires a bunch of different techniques
happening at the same time whereas
ray-tracing although it's very computer
intensive it takes it requires a beast
of a machine to do in real time it all
happens on the fly none of that has to
be computed outside there's no other
algorithm that's needed the technique
itself handles all of it and to great
effect so to this point it's only really
been used in movies right if we look at
our our favorite movies to the
inventor's movies and the empties that
use them exactly like any movies with
big effects in this day and age can use
them because again they use it for a
specific frame right it's something
that's recorded it's put on it's
digitized and it's not something that
has to happen real time so they can take
the time that they need to make those
effects look fantastic and it's not
something that that taxes the system so
to speak right um for gaming right
Tracy's been around for a long time like
ray tracing was introduced in like 2011
right by Intel exactly yeah and then it
was even talked about when it came to
and it goes back to this cloud
discussion about utilizing the cloud to
off put this sort of stuff this sort of
high computation stuff so you don't have
to do it locally right and it was talked
about um back and like the iPad 2 and
and telephones are finally getting to
the point where they could display these
high end graphics right yeah so at this
past GDC Microsoft introduced what they
called EXR mom and along with Intel um
and basically the XR is is the first
time you're implementing Direct X tools
I mean shoot I'm sorry ray tracing tools
into DirectX 12 it's gonna be part and
parcel with the DF 12 API meaning that
moving forward it technically every game
that utilizes DX 12 which is basically
any high-end triple play triple you know
it's your play game coming down the
pipeline is going to be using in some
way shape or form
um they kind of announced it in
conjunction with Nvidia in
nvidia has their own set of specific
tools for this um that they're going to
be using in their new vaults of GPUs
right touching now all this stuff is
fantastic if you guys have looked at
anything having to do with ray tracing
they look you see that the captain
phasma I think it's unreal I don't know
if it's unity or unreal I'm demo you can
see that the next step is you know
lifelike images like stuff that looks
like we're watching an actual movie um
for a long time it was you know does it
look like Pixar right and I think we've
gotten almost to the point where that
we've passed that right so this is the
next step the problem with it is that
you're gonna need a monster machine to
run this right so this is interesting
stuff for a couple of reasons one its
Microsoft and NVIDIA I mean AMD is
definitely in there and they're working
with this but the fact that it's
Microsoft and NVIDIA and they haven't
worked directly with Nvidia in terms of
the Xbox branch fir for a long time it's
interesting to think about what can
happen moving forward on the Xbox side
of things are they going to be
partnering with downwards eight is AMD
going to continue their partnership with
it with Playstation and whit's and with
Xbox moving forward in the console space
so let me ask you a quick questions up
so as of right now who is it baked in
with hardware wise is it Nvidia
no I mean hardware wise AMD has a
software solution for us mom and they
they're probably gonna be baking it into
their Xen CPU GPU combined stuff that's
coming out Oh
in all likelihood it's gonna be baked in
at the you know at the the metal level
there again like I said with Nvidia it's
the art yeah yeah exactly it's r-tx and
there's gonna be in their new GPUs - but
those are monster GPUs like a machine a
top-of-the-line machine right now cannot
run that stuff in real time see that was
my next question cuz I was gonna just
bring it for real term for the Lords of
listening that I like hearing ray
tracing and and we've heard this kind of
you know terminal technical
terminologies before in dx12
I guess the question comes down to
reading realistically can we even say
like next
Jen do we think with the next iteration
of Xbox one and the PlayStation 5 that
these technologies will be able to be
utilized like a fully ray-traced game
you know I'm saying like what do you
think I would say maybe next gen when we
get to the mid-cycle refresh when we get
to the X I would say it's feasible then
just because pricing like you're gonna
need a monster machine with these
next-gen GPUs they haven't really even
been announced yet to to kind of run
this stuff in real time I think it but
this is the caveat though it's being
brought up now because I think again go
back to the cloud stuff I think
Microsoft has figured out a way or it's
figuring out a way that a lot of this
stuff can be offloaded to the cloud and
not necessarily be handled locally right
weren't you so I don't know about an
entire game being rendered in this form
because I get like I said it's very comp
you intensive but I I see stuff and and
again when we talk about like that
crackdown and stuff like that that's
mostly physics stuff like physics
manhandle I'm talking about graphics
rendering you know locally whatever you
see on your screen
that's a whole different ball game um
the physics stuff I think they've been
working on it for a while I think that
makes more sense but who knows where
they're at I mean I again it gets
brought up because it's an exciting
thing to talk about the what graphics
are going to be at some point um but I
think they're kind of holding their
cards close to their chest and I think
they're closer in some respects that
others but like I still don't see it
being viable in a console for quite some
time just because of again form factor
you need to shrink the stuff down and
price notches I think 500 is the ceiling
and that's you know it's gonna be hard
to give a system you know especially you
know when we're talking about maybe
looking at next gen stuff 2019 2020 I
don't see it but you never know
you know you know I will say this there
they'll be the first ones to do it
Sony above
look I know you've been championing this
tech to me information to me for some
time put me schooling me so what do you
think about what was shown in demos at
GDC stuff where you at with this whole
ray-tracing super I like the way that
Microsoft is pushing the narrative did
you see the new commercial from the Xbox
one X imma shoot that over to you it's
why I told you phil was doing I love
Phil silence and the power narrative is
fantastic and he gives you little
breadcrumbs okay but he loves little
stuff to come out and the ray-tracing
he's like you're listening you know
we're pioneering this stuff and they
like yeah okay we heard about that
before he see what I let slide that out
and my god was just part of the extras
no real-time CGI graphics polygons it
was it was above and beyond what we are
expecting to come from and I know
sovereign is right do we expect to get
that in a home system anytime soon
not at all but what I would say is this
remember Microsoft has allowed a lot of
computations to come off of the disk
because they embedded a lot of the stuff
onto the graphics chip alright so
remember they have a lot of free cap
space when it comes to using the
horsepower maybe they find an algorithm
that it can fit in there they couldn't
remember their software company to get
this stuff to run at a base form on the
system that is an extra tool towards
developers I don't know what I think
they can run it on obviously there's
some aspects that it can be implemented
not like I guess the full way from yeah
like they'd still be like part
rasterization part you know ray tracing
and stuff like that you're rendering
buildings and stuff like that right if
it's not if you're not doing something
that's destructible in a moment then
maybe the building can be rendered that
way because and you're gonna see like
you know crazy shadows and crazy
textures on the building because there's
nothing going on with that building in
that scene in that moment that requires
it to have to be rasterized you know you
know a lot of people are that's what
they're trying to do like this mixing
with some rasterization some very
tracing you know full ray tracing though
that that's where that's where everybody
wants to be and that's a whole another
yes that's the workstation you guys do
know that also between between those
guys between Nvidia and Microsoft you
know epic is also there they're talking
about bringing real time ray tracing the
Unreal Engine this you know to where
that's gonna go is a good question I
think when we get to that point where
ray tracing is an entire game construct
this may be a time when you look at what
you're what you're looking at a
difference in generation when we're not
when we're not steps to link on consoles
anymore because remember if you're gonna
maintain backward compatibility and and
a an Xbox one X can't even run this your
next console can there is no way you're
gonna be out of two backward compatible
yeah yeah so you're gonna be talking
about it uh what people are now looking
for which is a new gen dachi
so because of the technic differences in
the tech in getting that implement it
would be so substantially different
you're saying what you're saying those
things there's no way possibly that
they're gonna be able to fall it because
that's been kinda like Microsoft mantra
right they want to they want to bring it
right you bring there's no console
behind
I got a disagree with thing a little bit
there because the thing is money
they're they're building all this into
DX 12 which is which they've been using
for quite some no right so I think
they've thought about that right I to me
they're thinking is that good we're
gonna build on this because if you think
about it how many true dx12 games have
come out says they've been talking about
it like if we remember if we go all the
way back to the launch of the Xbox one
and you know resolution gate happened in
everything and the power of the system
was in question then people they were
rumors about the secret sauce that and
when when dx12 was gonna get updated
they was gonna blow the place it out of
the water and it just that didn't come
to pass so just about it is that the x12
implementation across the board it's
been pretty slow so I think if they're
basing it on this and this is gonna be
the big you know basement level of this
stuff
I think they've thought about that I
don't know how they're gonna implement
it because stingers right like this is a
generational leap it should be a night
and day type thing so how do you figure
that in but I think they've thought
about that so well and I'm sure they
have the issue is you can only do so
much with the hardware you have at the
time how do they how do they get that if
this is targeting newer hardware which
obviously it is and and companies do
that they target higher hardware but
this is something that if it can't run
on an X for example in the way that it
can run on you know the X Box Y or
whatever they decide to call it what how
do they how do they rectify that mmm I
just don't know you know and if we start
talking about the cloud that's all well
and good for multiplayer game it's all
well and good for the multiplayer games
but how do you know the cloud
how do you do that when you're taking
your would you take you to your Xbox one
exon to a submarine underwater Internet
this is good good tech good stuff to see
about the future yeah I remember when
the Xbox 360 was was you know in its in
its mid cycle we started talking about
things like procedural generation we did
now a normal thing but back then man you
know when we said when we played I think
was morrowind and then what was it
called the tree that could procedurally
generate trees and foliage and stuff
like that and that was like the big
thing because it took it took resources
you know it took it took those intensive
resources that would normally have to
calculate and draw those trees in it and
it loosened it up a lot gave me power
back to developers to do other things
now you hear a lot about procedurally
generated content it's no point this is
something that you know that that
techies love to love to get into this is
just a little bit of a different realm
for you know for lack of better word
absolutely absolutely and this is good
man we're gonna see what happens in the
future with the what the Sun raised God
raised every game by JJ Abrams Lord King
next bad sea of thieves what is going on
let's see if these again I woke up to a
patch I woke up to an 18 gig patch just
when I heard all the current in the
content I'm having fun with my friends
okay so um what I've noticing is this
this this this move wave this list of
destiny too
did it wrong hmm as far as fixing things
after the noise became too loud mm-hmm
you understand and he tried to go fixing
it after the noise was deafening and no
one would hear them over the noise so
while the noise is starting to build I'm
noticing these Lilou companies for these
new games that are out there fixing it
as it goes buck G was hearing the noise
and a patch come out the week later and
the patcher come out the week later it's
night and day from the day of the launch
but that's a preview game yes of course
but and some people will say see if
thieves is a preview game I would beg to
differ but I will also say this it's an
evolving game isn't going to be the same
exact game that is launched I don't
think so I don't think with any MMO or
in that type of frame would be the same
exact game because they didn't learn
anything if it was so it's going to
change right and these implications are
changing week to week little patches
here little patches there and I'm saying
all these companies now is Microsoft now
and other companies are they listening
to you and getting these out in a timely
fashion for us and is dissociating the
crowd to quiet the noise mmm good one
it's a good one I mean it's definitely
you know something right now that's uh
being talked about in the in the
community is that acceptable and you
know at the st. at the same time we do
know that you know these games are
service games tend to be something that
are evolving right there's something
that has a foundation that when it first
starts may be completely different you
know six months to a year down the road
the question just comes down to is this
acceptable for you and then for some
people hey it's no problem they're
having fun they're enjoying other people
they like nope this is not enough
content and I really don't think it's a
wrong answer to it it's just what do you
like I remember the original destiny and
the things how it was back then and in
some of the systems that was in place
and then I remember you know the taken
King came out it was almost like a
complete
overhaul and all this other stuff that
went on again it just comes down to the
initial content
do you like the universe do you are you
invested in that ecosystem if you are
and you like it and I think we'll see a
themes they've got something really
unique going on is really not a lot of
pirate simulators going on the
foundation is there the game does look
beautiful I do understand the complaints
you know it's not enough content or
maybe just the fresh effects to the
fetch quest or repetitive blah blah blah
it's on you you know so it's up to you
if you want to stick around with it
let me feel Lord sting and loss of so
welcome the games as a service honestly
I and name me the two games right now
that since they have launched have
continued to show up every month like
clockwork on MPD chars I give you two
one ones the big one the Granta yep
mm-hmm and the other is Rainbow six
siege right every month these are games
that that start out in one position and
evolve over time and you can you can say
what you want about Grand Theft Auto but
Rockstar has perfected the ability to
drop content into that game and keep
people going to an extent I've never
seen before
yeah the sale is like that yeah good
because you know Rainbow six siege six
in the top 20 here and there Grand Theft
Auto is routinely in the top ten and
they just introduced what racing they
just introduced outright just
straight-up racing to the game for the
online yep Rainbow six evolved over time
from being just a very generic
multiplayer non single-player game to a
an amazing experience that continues
add hey you know even though those even
though these games don't show up
themselves you have to credit games like
the division for doing the same thing so
yeah the division was pretty shallow too
at first you had the dark zone you had
the the main game but it was still the
same thing over and over and over you
ran into PvE stuff you got in the dark
zone and you kind of battle it out with
other people but it's it's what they
bring to the table post-launch
that continues to have people playing it
right this is where sea of thieves is
this is where this is where we're at the
beginning of this adventure with Co
thieves and it's up to and that it's up
to rare to to add that content and if
they don't they will suffer but they had
that this is you know the the judgment I
don't want to harp on to it harp down
and earlier the judgment on this game to
me has been a little bit unfair
considering those other games that are
out there that are doing that you know
Elder Scrolls online is another one you
know we can go through you know this is
where our industry is this is where
folks think they can make the best money
and Rockstar has kind of set the set the
stage for it
Ubisoft look what they did was far cry
with car far far cry 5 I looked at that
game I was watching Nathan do a stream
that on our twitch channel and all I
could think of is damn this looks like a
reskin Ghost Recon wildlands and I don't
say that I don't say that it and I don't
say that this is knock on the game
Ubisoft understands what that what they
need to do with that game to keep it
going
mm mm and so you know be money saying
kind of where I'm getting at Ubisoft
right now is is and Rockstar those are
the two they're right now the best -
yeah game to the service companies
understand what the people want and
they're giving it to him and it's up to
rare to follow suit absolutely Louis um
what's your feeling on it
on what stinger said about specifically
uh Ubisoft at what money saying is true
and I think I talked about this a little
bit last week let me talk about the
tents and stuff
I think Ubisoft is poised to sort of
take that take at least uh you know the
the people's champion crown away from EA
and Activision because of the way they
handle these games they still handle
them like their small games you know
that these massive games they take it to
you who want you to come back to but the
way they handle they give you single
player DLC they still give you a season
pass right but then they give you modes
that are more in line with what the you
would think of as games as a service
right and then on top of that they've
been able to balance giving you stuff
that's cosmetic with stuff that changes
the game like when you look at Rainbow
six siege you get new operators and the
new operators function differently right
but what it's not a stat based thing
right they give you they give you like
different abilities and ways to go about
things and I think that's where sea of
thieves to me has to progress right
obviously when you're trying to make a
game that doesn't exclude anybody like
right if I can stop playing see if these
right now and the way it stands right
now if I come back in a year and go into
that game I'm not necessary gonna be
behind anyone right I'm not in terms of
like progression and stuff like that I
couldn't jump driving or cockpit right
exactly exactly so to me what they need
to do is figure out within game how you
create that loop for people to keep
coming back right obviously they already
have the hoarding stuff about it right
right the thieving part about it yeah
exactly
they have that part down obviously you
have to fix her and stuff like
respawning and whatnot to not make it so
cheap where you know you're continuously
trying to kill the same dude keeps
respawning on his ship stuff like that
but i think that's where they're gonna
survive it I think at first I kind of
saw the the no progression thing as a
detriment right because you look at
destiny you look at mill Avenger there's
a big one exactly um but what I see that
they would they've done with this game
is
by putting it on game past where the the
barrier to entry is possibly very low it
makes it so it's always an appealing
option to somebody that's not gonna cost
them a super amount of time if they
don't want to or super amount of money
if they don't want to
you're always it's always gonna be in a
very inviting State so it's just gonna
be a matter of the content supporting
that on and just making again creating
that pirate world whether it be like I
was thinking about things like okay like
you know put people in a pub together
let them do you know whatever drinking
games or like trying to shoot at each
other or like a real stuff like that I
think the world feel more alive a little
more piratey exactly make it feel alive
and I think they'll be fine if you
bought it at 60 bucks and it's not what
you expected I can see that argument I
can see that argument but I think the
game pass model makes it so that that
blow is lessened and I think it's only
gonna serve to help the game in the
future I see this game in a year being
something that we're gonna be talking
about a positive light I think it really
bothered apply I think it's one of the
fun most polarizing games but it's
definitely I see both sides you know and
I definitely I understand you know I
understand the group that's enjoying it
you know me and and having fun with all
the stuff that's currently in the game
and I see the the group that says hey
you know right now it's not enough for
me and maybe as it continues to evolve
they come to get all right into and they
get invested you know I'm saying so yeah
we'll see we'll see what happens but
that's a good good type of King I know
I'm keeping you on Easton you got a cut
[Applause]
come hang with us hebrews you can't eat
any bread right now but at least
there we go and we make it we make a
great brisket you would appreciate this
and I also wanna shout out to Lord our
Lord Adonai Lord Sam tobert it's got a
great article right now up on it and
it's the Atari VCS the details have been
revealed for the new Atari retro themed
box so right now is looking like yeah
it's codenamed VCS and um lately the CEO
well basically saying it's just new at
our device that design for today's
living room will include PC and online
entertainment features there's also
gonna be on some retro aspects to it
like a retro box Marco console kind of
thing that consumers may want to do it
it has the whole you know atari
woodgrain retro feel to it now the specs
have not been finalized but we've been
privy to some information and um looks
like the performance will be comparable
to a higher-end PC laptop supposed to be
4k HDR 60 frames per second
AMD 86 processor portable storage he's
got the the Bluetooth bit the USB to USB
3.0 yadda yadda yadda so I did I did not
I did not actually it's gonna be a AMD
Radeon Radeon exclusive emoji what is it
but stinger is it is it is it an SOC
like everything like a console what is
it gonna be like from the look of it
it's gonna have to be I mean this thing
is tiny right I don't know how I can
supposedly suppose that's all that's all
that was that was bled out and it's
actually not an MLG exclusive came from
seen it but they don't that's all the
only other thing that we know which may
drive a lot of the Headroom
Oh Linux yes yes that and it definitely
supposed to be you know people asked
about you know what type of bullet what
type of content will be you know the
gains and stuff like that will it be
mostly retro a variety of I'm supposed
to be a you know the retro content from
Atari reimagine classics and supposedly
they're working with game developers and
content creators you know sharing more
details about the Atari nobody where did
you learn to fly this is what I'm talk
understanding a series of terrible
choices now he heard that is GPU inside
the box I heard this not so I'm telling
you this scrap all of this crap crap it
scrap this vaporware put this away
so controllers for your app make a hat
to play retro Atari game this is where
your money is that right make an app for
retro Atari games put it on everybody
system and sell controllers you sell
controllers that work with your games
and you can come out with some little
marketing technique it works best with
an old-school Atari controller I don't
care how you spin it
do not put this crap out here nobody's
buying it as a place cuz they said that
they see it as a place that you know
parents want their kids to play Netflix
and I'll be watching Netflix and stuff
like that so this is gonna be the PC for
your TV the guy had to get to you has a
black robe as they'd like to tell you
stuff like for somebody else a middle
man can run it you know what i'ma break
it down this way thing are you buying it
the Lemony Snicket
the Nostalgia hit me for about five
minutes and I mean then common sense
walked in the door $200 are you buying
it not a chance
sovereign are you buying it not at $200
he announced like you getting every
smile can everyone do buy you gave
yourself the stipulations with fire it's
a bet on that price if they talking to
to over 250 ah I can't well so what's
some price that you will purchase 99
yeah like it gotta be but see the
problem is they've already locked
themselves in this piece yeah ecosystem
kind of a deal so it's like and someone
has to remaster ET when you're seven
years old that game is great you don't
want that's that's 64-bit we did the
math back back that Baghdad and and
except for tempest 2000 yeah there were
like two and a half good games for the
Jaguar there was there was Tempest Java
soul was it alien vs. predator right an
alien vs predator which is unbelievable
and defenders out
looks like over time did you go back to
really look at what you know what it is
I thought we were starving you know how
when you sit at a table nobody like rice
grains for two three years and then they
actually put a piece of bread on the
table and look at that aliens vs.
predator understand exactly why they
gave you a giant tollable as a CD player
for that day two hundred and fifty
dollars screensavers I'm in the camp of
knowing crap when I see it all right and
I mean that can all right I know this I
will buy anything I have a Wonder Swan I
have a one form regular I'm wonderswan
color high and have a wonderful on
switch tell me you have an engage is
somebody over in this Sony camp I don't
know if is mark Jamal I don't know who's
all I mean in this Atari camp so look at
like and Sony like I want it to be
something Sonia I want them to say they
purchased these dudes Oh somebody is
controlling the purse strings over there
and I heard was supposed to be
crowdfunded or something that's where
they lost me just this just going
through the whole gist of this crap so
we didn't really get past it and I don't
want to talk bad about Atari because
it's like talking bad about your grandpa
was a beautiful thing fuzz but when
grandpa gets crazy and senile he's
running around naked in the street we
got a laugh
[Laughter]
just to get into the weeds out to why
this really is not a great idea
right so first of all yeah the
crowdfunded thing is it just shows you
don't have confidence in what you're
bringing to the table and nobody else
had enough confidence the whole will
start thing the whole lack of a graphics
card thing you know what for something
that's more you you're looking at an SOC
the same thing as what you have in the
Xbox the same things what you have into
PlayStation the thing with that is right
they compared it to a high-end laptop
these days right laptop these days
that's misleading because a high-end
laptop these days is running a desktop
GPU not it's nothing different to it
right so let's say it's running a 1050
or 1060 right so it's capable of
something in the range of you know
vanilla Xbox one or something but now
let's watch one to two Xbox one ants or
something like that maybe ps4 pro stuff
but again this is something that's
bringing a price up right price is a big
deal for this because again they're
trying to compete with other companies
that already have stuff in this space I
could be talking about an all-inclusive
4k machine like you know you already
have Amazon you already have Apple that
has these sort of these sort of all in
one sort of machines that are still
trying to give you gaming on that too so
you have people with more and then when
you look at Xbox and Playstation
these are ecosystems that have a lot
more robust offerings and they would
have so you're telling me now that you
have you don't have to create another
storefront then I'm gonna have to buy
from it's not happening unless you
unless you get steam and you get you get
steam and you get Netflix onboard and
you get
and maybe you get Microsoft on board to
have the Microsoft Store on there
something like that look at that exactly
like it's one of those things like
you're gonna have to convince people
convince people that from the ground up
you've built this thing that they should
be confident in then you look at other
stuff like you know like the Linux stuff
is cool cuz it's open-ended I know they
had something where they were gonna let
people like like like a sandbox so to
speak where they were gonna let people
like make homebrew and stuff like that
yeah that's cool but that leaves you
wide open to blow and everything out and
like and being a PSP and like people
modding it left and right so I mean
there's so much stuff there to be honest
man this is what they needed to do if
they were gonna do this they should have
gone the NES mini and the SNES mini
route make one thing give me something
for like 60 bucks it has all the Atari
2600 games on it that looks like an
Atari 2600 a one-shot deal
and then the Nexus you could do it
without that they have that yeah but I
mean a real one like a real one well I
guess they they got the the anniversary
edition they do have that actually you
can buy it's called the Atari flashback
I've seen he's the one but the console
or is it just like I know that something
to have the controller and the games are
all in the control no no no there's a
it's called the Atari flashback 8 it has
105 games it's it's it's a plastic
version of the console when it said it's
got two regular regular joysticks it's
edson emulator like everything else it's
the same company that makes the Genesis
1 and the they have like a handheld
version you know and honestly they do
make the flash black classics for Xbox
ps4 Union eat games on on a console got
some Lakes games on my head
they want to sell you on the nostalgia
of their brands and the things that I
think that's the way to go and then like
next year you can do a 5200 and that not
many people had a 5200 it would have
next 7800 then and at you know an atom
or something like that you know I think
if you're gonna do that and you're gonna
charge that much money you were going to
Atari is gonna have to remaster these
games yes like they're gonna have to
bring new version s like a new you know
it's one thing to just throw centipede
from the 1980s onto this thing and
Jordan 254 they're gonna have to do like
they did like the Dreamcast has a a 3d
version of centipede that they remade
they're gonna have to remiss their that
and bring it they're gonna have to make
new games you know make this the consult
make this the consult you bring your
test drive unlimited back on right this
is a console that you take that you get
into your this would work so this would
work if you Atari's IPS are pretty vast
people people don't remember them
because again they're not as you know
we're talking about in the 70s and 80s
and so you know they had games like
adventure they had game they had combat
imagine bringing a tank combat game back
into this era you know imagine taking
some of those IPs that you have and
remaking them for today imagine a brand
new three-dimensional breakout you know
those Arcana you do that and that's
where your games go you could tell me
you would not jump at a brand new
asteroids or a brand new Missile Command
or a combo
because you know why it's not good to
have a new asteroid shooting rocks is
not fun they said they put it in like a
place on worlds just because I'll think
about it
Oh Giza Lord actually which is like do
you think because we have this close
attachment to these companies these
games and these brains that we're not
thinking outside the bubble way like a
younger generation like an Lord addict
and these kids out here would not even
care less these these titles would not
even have that same meaning to them you
think that maybe we made me kind of
living in a vacuum a little bit I think
what we're living is in in a world where
Oh hand held now that they hold your
hand from start to finish
and they you know they pat you on the
butt when you do well that people I
don't think people could handle a yars
revenge these days I think they were
they would play it for five seconds ago
and then it was then they would stop
because we're so trained we're what what
just happened you did okay okay no no we
have a visitor I heard there were naked
grandpas I can't even get him on my show
here he comes running the yard we're
talking about it or i have certain for
them but it's 2018
i don't know what they would do to get
me to buy a how much is that now $300
but they trying to go with this whole pc
with a linux OS and also mushroom yeah
also a veteran also feel so you know
widow so what what are they so it's
running linux but it's gonna run pc
games on the steam but you would assume
that yeah no I would I wouldn't assume
that they tell you if this thing was
made by Apple worried be all over that
ain't buying it they don't
market do you think they have a market
what would the market be yeah that's
thank you yes the question there is no
market wouldn't it be better if they
were nap yeah it makes perfect sense
yeah yeah there wasn't there wasn't
there is an Atari app where you could
play all the old games you download the
app on you know Android Apple Iowa
whatever you have it on they have that
yeah yeah they have there's an app
there's a mobile app now or you can play
you know play asteroids centipede
Missile Command you can play all those
old games I'm on their website playing
him right now
yeah sorry calm the point of buying a
box it's good my point was my point was
remaking it if they were wanting to be
successful if they had they wanted a
formula to be successful with only on
those they would have they would have to
dip into their catalogue and remake some
of these games you know we're talking
about we don't want old games and yet
huh we talked about we don't want old
games yet we're buying the latest Tomb
Raider anyway how old is Tomb Raider but
it's you know it's not to murder from
ps1 it's a brand-new to murder mm-hmm
right well more so in the Dreamcast day
they did it by turning it into a 3d game
hmm I don't know I just it doesn't sound
like it would work to me the Missile
Command or well let me ask you this
little worry what about from a
standpoint of just if they came from the
standpoint of just tell I'll tell you
what will work testing er I'll tell you
what absolutely will work for Atari if
they do this if you can buy an Atari box
and it comes with a naked grandfather
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
even from a retro console we wouldn't
even be present I got the press guy game
he gave me some documents that I was
privy to and it's kind of funny because
some of the questions that they asked
and he was like you know some people
complained about the pricing why is it
closer to the game consoles you know as
far as the current ones as opposed to
the micro console and then they asked
him you know what truly sets Atari VCS
aside from these other consoles and the
answer no lie gentlemen it's new and
it's from Atari it just showed me that
stated just show me a little bit of how
out of touch they are and it was just I
was shocked like I showed a little show
the other lords a couple of these are
these questions that were asked by the
press you don't see these guys at the
GDC and it just to have the audacity to
have that kind of a statement its new
and it's from Atari so you should want
it coming out
thank you did not ask his biggest thing
yeah we lost a little bit there you go
yeah apparently though you guys didn't
like me talking about a Tariq as I said
you've been muted guys we weird we're
older we sucked now so please you know
buy our stuff of course we're gonna of
course we're gonna do that everybody
does that look they're there they're
going to play on their nostalgia I get
it
I my point wasn't that I'm gonna buy
this thing because I'm expecting them to
do this I was asking the simple question
of would you want that would I was
saying that that Atari strategy to work
for Atari strategy to work they've got
to dip into that catalog and remake
these games for a modern time I'm not
saying that they could just put Missile
Command and lunar lander on this thing
and and go to town I'm saying that they
would have to do what they did would
like I said I use centipede as the
example when the dreamcast came out they
brought centipede out they didn't just
throw centipede on the screen they made
it a 3d adventure game that was a little
more open world it was you know you did
things you you didn't just shoot it
stuff coming at you that's the kind of
thing that they would have to figure out
how to do for a modern console if they
were gonna try to make that work in this
market otherwise so I'm with Fleur King
we don't have a play there's no place in
the in the is Atari trying to be
relevant in the modern console space or
they just trying to make a mastaba
console that you can also maybe play
some PC games on actually yeah it's a
combo because it's not just a retro
console they're actually trying they
they're saying when people are asking
questions about you know the games they
say no it's a completely new Atari
device design for today's living room
that will include PC and online
entertainment driven features that
distinguish it from other products yes
well what we have right now is a
performance will be comparable to a
higher-end PC laptop 4k HDR 60 frames
per second AMD x86 processor on board
and expandable storage and then you know
there's still no talk of a video car per
se in the initial document but Colonel
Ross thing you know he's what you said
he said it will definitely be was in the
video what you said the video ready are
AMD Radeon Radeon right so that that's
what we're hearing right now so there
are some specs they say they still gonna
finalize it as it comes you know as we
get closer to April and that's when a is
supposed to have a pre-order date
whenever whenever we've had four
consoles in a generation one is going I
don't know because it's at Orion you'll
put that respective consoles and older
people in gaming I'll still remember the
old Nintendo games and they do well I
don't know if there are enough older
Torian maybe Gomez gob viously we know
what's going on obviously enormous guy
and a couple people how many of you guys
only because I'm gonna get it for that
next DLC because having that free update
they supposed to be a lot of game
changes that's happened since then yeah
better alright well I wonder if I you'll
be actually able to meet other
adventurers in the game only because of
the fact that I played it when it came
out on the PlayStation and it's just
just it's so vast that it's hard to meet
people which is kind of benefit and a
weakness to the game because you do want
to be social with it but I don't know
I'm not really a big on social gaming
anyway so the single-player adult it was
something I'd be into it's it's more of
what I want out of sea of thieves where
I can just go out and explore on my own
you can discover things so I agree I'm
actually interested lost thing what's
your feeling on it are you interested
I'm not sure I mean I didn't I didn't
bite on it on the on the PlayStation
I wasn't it seemed like a walking flying
simulator yeah yeah I wasn't I wasn't
keen on it then I'm not sure I'm keen on
it now look I think if you really wanted
to to make this work for me not I after
a couple months I might put it in game
pass you put a gamepad an onion along
it'll be it's a good point that's
actually a good point
Lord solve what do you feel like I even
buy it on the PlayStation and it's one
of those games that I I don't have time
to play structured games that much so
I'm a game where I have to make my own
fun but I mean I may have it by proxy
anyway because I think I think about to
get it so mm-hmm
Lord King are you you happy that the
beta testing trades over what I sit back
and I watch and I listen to all the
stuff that people talk about and the
game did have me excited for the
PlayStation and then once the game came
out an embargo lifted and they said they
didn't find a single soul playing the
game I said whoa maybe there's no one
that purchased again I was like no a lot
of people purchased it because I've seen
a lot of complaints right Oh after
period of time I always kept my eye on
the game no because I was interested in
the game and then I've seen it it turned
and morph and morphed into what the
developers were trying to initially get
to us and I think what the next update
they're getting closer to that reality
of that grandioso thing that they was
talking about I truly believe that on
different servers that actually work in
this number now and this is not going at
Sony now your opponent about with the
power of the cloud or three space
travelers in the galaxy
and that way they did add a new they get
out a new planet to the game for the
Expos that you can visit the planets
called deal you can mine for ray tracing
the next big the DLC called next it
actually has some stuff in a foundation
update Pathfinder update we'll see let's
see how it goes so hopefully I will say
this it's depending on how it's priced
for me because if they try to $60 it I
don't know I have to agree with sixty
it's still sixty dollars on the
PlayStation Network wow they're gonna
sell this at full price that's why I
said that
if they don't put this in the game pass
I don't know because I don't know how
well it's gonna do honestly I mean yet
there's the people that are that are
that have been pining for it you know
like the like little little Johnny who
wrote him the letter
oh yes please make it for Xbox and hit a
home run for me you know I I thought it
was I thought it was funny his business
partner probably wrote that note there's
there's a few people that are gonna buy
this because it's 4k it's gonna be HDR
it's gonna be enhanced to the X but you
know the game also launched what two
years ago two years ago I mean how how
much are people really pining for this
game
[Music]
do I fall can I fall into a pit in this
game hey if it took if it took no man's
sky two years to mature and our content
to it I'm thinking to see
[Laughter]
responsibilities but real quick new ILP
poll this week into with the topic with
the recent release of PlayStation
exclusives like no man sky and
hell-blade now coming to the Xbox
platform does this give you extra
incentive to pick them up eh
no been there done that on PlayStation
already Hellboy is a great game though
he'll plays great yeah yes but only with
enhancement or extra content or C I
don't care it let's it's a bigger Saudi
French my lord King do not necessarily
reflect my god this has been fantastic
and you know if we keep going a little
longer we can hit that three-hour mark
so much respect huge respect man well
what you guys are doing love the retro
of love that she educate me you doubt
here about what gaming is supposed to be
about and we had to make the treaty
happen we did you went waking the five
people find you in obviously we know
energy note no one tonight what you know
we won't be right so we won't be on
tonight you know and we ran out of
respect for the Easter holiday and the
folks who are doing what they're doing
we are you'll find us on Twitter which
is a twitch.tv slash og underscore NL
gaming and we could also if you also
follow us on twitter at a G underscore
NL game and we post a lot of that stuff
there we are on our podcast is Sunday
nights from 9:00 p.m. to roughly 2:00 in
the morning until about 11:00 right you
know we we need to we need to bring the
iron Lords to our kingdom absolutely
alone that has to happen that has to
happen Monday is the Lord's Day yes it
we have to make that effort yes Lord
worry boy in the building yes such a
pleasure to have great opinions on
Twitter man loved his takes on stuff
Lord worry what kind of find people
finds you know alter-egos Peterman
[Laughter]
please follow this guy Twitter vet great
great great perspectives on gaming this
guy's been around he knows what's going
on out here
lucky punch
there he is Luger bring back pit fighter
my bad
right there but man like first digitize
kind of girl for the little worried web
ad much appreciated good to see you
active out here in these streets where
can the people also not find you you're
also aluminum would not find you online
oh yeah big salads Lord's finger and
Lord worry ward for joining us on this
geriatric thank you for blessing us
which have online presence always a
pleasure to have you as a guest of the I
love it's crazy because portal and all
the stuff this week we're packs guys and
what I would like for you to do is I
would like if you're interested in any
game and you would like me to capture
any footage on any specific game hitman
at DM on Twitter I will definitely take
the time out to get at least two to
three minutes on your game give you an
overview on the game Sundays is gonna be
our run through game run through days we
are fully booked from
today we get their money's worth
yes I'm raising my hand and list in case
you can't see me I'm raising my hand
here I want I want the messenger
I want King and addict to specifically
focus on switch games permanent note in
my brain he'll write it down now we'll
go to your game and I will demo actually
there's a request the channel viper
strike says king go fine and check out
light for so that's them all right hit
me on Twitter like I just told you then
um I will take note because I'm will be
there also wanted before I forget I want
salute to our good friend Lord Erik to
call this for landing the role of the
god of war we are very proud of him
gamer checkout aisle P number 33 he was
on the show this guy is retro to the
core he knows his gaming this is one of
the best the entire Tekken move list go
check out his channel Erik Jacobus
salute man for landing that relationship
with Santa Monica studios and being the
new cradle for the generation these kids
are not ready is gonna be good man so
last but not least like what king said
the laws will be in Boston and PAX East
there's most likely not gonna be an LP
next week because of traveling the
schedule like that but we got some
surprises cooking like Lord King said
please stay tuned is gonna be funny on
everybody not gonna be in a podcast next
week because this week you had to
seven-year-old
[Laughter]
tomorrow I'm gonna be posting up the new
t-shirts on Twitter knit me and a damn
price and stuff will be inside there
I got you it's gonna be the packs
exclusive t-shirts so it's definitely
gonna be something that you definitely
wanna watch we got anything for the
geriatrics - my t-shirts last gentleman
put a t-shirt on Grampa so he's not
ready happy everyone Fortuna did have a
good play on gamers